Marjorie Taylor green a radical
republican congresswoman who has been
kicked off of all of her committees and
fined for uh refusing to wear masks on
the floor of the house to to high heaven
she's been fine to high heaven at this
point she is now lying that Joe Biden is
paying Tick-Tock influencers now as is
almost always the case sometimes they
make up
nonsense whole cloth like when she
talked about Jewish space lasers or
lasers as Lindsey Graham called them
that was completely made up
but sometimes there's like a kernel of
something and it is true that the Biden
Administration met with Tick-Tock
influencers there was rampant rampant
Russian propaganda on Tick Tock and Tick
Tock is a growing platform we now are on
to we're taking Tick Tock seriously
because we're having such explosive
growth there nearly a hundred thousand
followers already I think Tick Tock has
grown faster than any platform we've
ever been on for us tick tocks it's
growing and so the Biden White House met
with a bunch of tick tock influencers
they didn't pay them they didn't pay
them and Marjorie Taylor green says that
not only were they paid they were paid
off and paid off as an additional
pejorative connotation that it's you
know people are being given money to say
specific things they don't believe take
a listen to this
and what is the White House doing as the
world slides dangerously close to
devastating World War
paying off Tick-Tock influencers to lie
for them more concerned with favorable
headlines from The Washington Post and
the New York Times than avoiding World
War more concerned with social media
likes than protecting American jobs and
families so of course none of that is
true uh and there are numerous reports
about this uh Fortune Magazine Biden is
using Tick Tock to fight back against
Russia's reported use of influencers to
spread propaganda
um the White House countered holding by
the way it wasn't even like they flew
people to DC they did a zoom briefing
about Ukraine for 30 Tick-Tock stars
like that that's the whole story that's
the whole story and it says that
National Security Council staffers and
Jen saki uh gave updates and
um I mean it's it's almost like a just
kind of like a non-story
um
and there has been significant use of
Tick Tock by a apparent Russian
propaganda
nodes I guess we would call them to
spread uh just so doubt about the
innocence of Ukraine in the context of
the invasion Etc and as is often the
case with a lot of these right Wingers
if they spent
10 of the time that they spent lying
about what Democrats are doing
ten percent of that time
working to actually fix a problem
the country would be dramatically better
off and this is one of the great
frustrations which is we see the clip
it's 23 seconds of Marjorie Taylor green
uh lying about Biden paying off Tick
Tock influencers and we debunk it pretty
quickly it's just it's not true it was a
zoom meeting no one was paid that's all
it was great we've established that but
we are constantly kind of playing catch
up in the sense that there are real
problems to solve here even when it
comes to Russia and Ukraine what is
going to be the long-term economic
impact what should be the U.S
perspective as we become accustomed to
The Invasion as you can already see
there's less coverage of it even now the
invasion's still going on but once a
story gets stretched out you start to
see less coverage
um or different types of coverage and so
what should be the continued attitude
and media coverage and sanction
framework and all these different things
and these are real things to figure out
what about Ukrainian refugees what about
arming Ukraine but stopping short of the
line that Biden Drew which is troops on
the ground these are all serious
important things and Marjorie Taylor
green is out there saying Biden's paying
tick-tockers and it's just a flat out
and complete lie and the I I hate to use
that tired phrase this is why we can't
have nice things but in a literal sense
the fact that these are conversations
that have to be pushed back against or
these are these are lies that have to be
pushed back against there's only 24
hours in a day and people got to sleep
right and and so by having to say none
of this stuff is happening in order to
protect the reputation of the people
that are actually working hard to try to
solve problems we lose time and
resources and just headspace to actually
deal with those problems and it's a very
sad thing let me know your thoughts you
can find me on Twitter at dpacman also
make sure that you are following us on
Tick Tock where you can find us at Dave
David packman show we are doing separate
Tick Tock only updates on the Russian
invasion of Ukraine which you can follow
there we'll take a quick break and be
back with a very packed Friday show for
you today
one of our sponsors is cometeer coffee
cometeer coffee is delicious I can tell
you firsthand and they've discovered the
best way to brew preserve and deliver
coffee their Brewing process captures
over 2 000 flavor compounds then the
coffee is flash frozen locking in the
flavor it arrives at your home Frozen in
a fully recyclable capsule all you have
to do is melt it by adding hot water or
cold water for iced coffee it takes
seconds it's the most convenient way
that I have ever made coffee I've been
impressed with how the process protects
the flavor I really enjoy cometeer they
have a variety of flavor options light
medium and dark single origin and
Blended coffee roasts from the best
specialty Roasters you'll get twenty
dollars off when you go to cometeer.com
Pacman the link is underneath this video